the white king is lacking shelter so
Magus doing everything he can to put his
pieces in front of it but Fab is going
after the D5 pawn and he's got passers
of his own at some point Fabian are
pushing his pawns but some nervous moves
from both players real nerves now
showing Fabiano giving a check with the
black Rook the problem is Black's pawns
act as shelter he doesn't really want to
push them until necessary but big threat
the black Rook threatening to go to F3
with a nasty pin on the White Queen all
the checks look at that white king
though just too be no protection around
it fabulous needs to pounce needs to win
this game he's outplayed Magnus wa and
there's a check on B2 is that uh super
dangerous for white king forcing it on
the a file so the king can run the
question is can it hide and it's hiding
in front of that pawn on B4 on the left
hand side of your screen you see
magnus's King there aren't too many
pieces remaining he's out in the open
can that de Pawn suddenly become a queen
is Magnus actually one with the upper
hand it's really possibly turning around
right now all three results possible a
few checks the position repeating itself
will Fabiano bail out with a draw this
position's been seen already if he keeps
checking the white king he wants more he
wants more he's playing for the win no
safe squares for magnus's King you have
to go onto the C file have to step
forward you have to run forward with the
white king but I think it's losing you
go up to C7 and go dling the black queen
steps up one square to A7 with check and
I think it's an aming match The Rook
will slide over at the end I think that
Magnus is about to get checkm it and
Magness he slows down but he's got six 6
seconds to decide now The Rook can go
onto the c f and win Queen
he gives up his Queen Magnus cast and
surely Fabiana is going to take it but
look at the white Pawn the remaining
white Pawn is so far Advanced still not
over yet Magnus has lost his Queen but
he's still fighting he's fighting
because it's all relying on these two
pawns moving ahead and Fabiano can run
on seconds and he can watch this with
Just 4 seconds on the clock I think he
made this quick moves to gain the
increment reminder to everybody 3
seconds added every single move you make
so a quick check go block that pawn and
then push your own pawns Fabby can win
this game even if he loses Queen for
those two pawns then he can push the
Pawns of his own a rook can't stop but
he give him check wow he just blundered
the pawn with check he should have
pushed the other one the G Pawn wrong
choice there and Magnus is alive look at
those white pawns paralyzing the black
queen and this can be scary for black
because now the queen can't move
anywhere with the check without allowing
the D Pawn to promote Magnus is does he
have enough to hold this well problem
for Magnus is that g Pawn will be a
decoy it's have to sacrifice himself The
Rook on D3 can't move because in the D7
Pawn in front of the queen will be
captured both sides they're struggling a
bit here fa doesn't know where to go but
now W for Magnus brings his Rook all the
way down hit he chooses the wrong Square
he trapped his own Queen and it's from
Jake Magnus Carson does the unbelievable
he wins down a queen wow miracles do
happen that was crazy stuff and we will
break it down in more detail later
Magnus Carson on the brink of defeat
turns it around and wins unbelievable
turn around Fabiano completely outplayed
Magnus Carlson but by fa's own words
Magnus is so resilient that you may get
a winning position but actually securing
the full point super difficult and it
was here where the drama began magnus's
King has been living a Charmed Life it
did get checked now this wins the White
Queen but this is only the beginning and
after the king dropped back we saw a
crazy position with White's far Advanced
Pawn suddenly trapping The Black Queen
forcing it to hide on a passive square
but if we fast forward just a few moves
as both sides started pushing their
pawns it was this moment
let it slip he chose the right idea as I
mentioned but first he should have
pushed the G Pawn H3 he simply forgot
that Rook takes Pawn came with a check
no time for Black's Queen to take this
Pawn this is not a deflection and once
the black king moved away the white Rook
slid back suddenly from a winning
position Fabiano went to a drawish
position but it was more heartbreak to
come a few moves down the line after
this check from White he simply put his
King on the wrong Square King to F7
still holds the balance because after
the Rooks like slides up black queen has
a checking square a safe square instead
he blocked the Queen's escape and
allowed Rook to E8 nothing to be done
white will make a new Queen next move
just wow is what we have to say about
that game Min as what will you say yeah
um I don't know it seemed that some
point we were both playing for for win
there u i mean of course a lot of things
happened before that but we were both
playing for a win then he was start
playing me at some point I was down to
seconds and then I don't know I don't
know what happened but uh I mean at some
point I started pushing my pawns I lost
my queen but um somehow I managed to to
win I have no idea what is the secret
there to to stay I guess calm when you
lose your queen there and eventually
win I don't know uh
I at least I had a clear plan which was
to push my
pawns but it was um yeah it was a mess
what what was the emotions there in the
final
minutes
um I don't know I mean at Dan it was
just disbelief cuz um he was about to
put his King on the right square and
then he put it on the wrong square and
lost on the spot so was bit
surprising how good is it to win a fight
like this no no of course it feels great
so um and for the match it's it's huge
heart rate at the end there what was
it I don't know my is usually not that
high but I would guess higher than usual
probably congrats and good luck at next
one thank
[Music]
you